we're here with the two best guests any
party could ever want dana carvey and
david yeah
dana spade
dana spade davis
brother from another mother look at that
guy that's right
well next up we have this weird story of
a stolen sasquatch the ap is reporting
that a seven foot tall sasquatch made of
metal was stolen off a front lawn in
michigan it's described as rusty brown
um and sharp around the edges
authorities say there was a white van
with tinted windows spotted nearby
and whoever snatched this squatch that
sounds dirty
must be really good because they had to
use a bolt cutter guys what do you think
who's doing this
um
i'm kind of into supernatural stuff i
think sasquatch
decided one day to simply walk away
i think the bolt cutters weren't even
involved i think that's satisfied
turned yeah turned into something real i
mean i have a 30-foot
kind of toy loch ness monster in my pool
so wow i like giant yeah nothing
no i just made that up
i love it it is not no drew you're right
maybe it's a the guy's desperate for an
anniversary gift for his wife or
something
nothing a woman likes more than a rusty
oh beat up 700 pound dirty sasquatch
none of this phases me except for the
white band yeah right the thing that
scars me the most in this story is the
white bass i think oj whenever i see a
white van i think oj
i just think oj yeah i i'm so scared of
fans i've always wanted to see a
sasquatch i got close once it was a bear
week in provincetown yeah
there we
[Music]
[Applause]
you're welcome hey finally you guys
here's a question have you ever crushed
super hard on someone who's not even
real i'll explain metro reports it's
very common to have an intense crush on
a fictional character even if that
character is a cartoon and i have
bravely said here on the show that my
first crush was on aladdin okay i was
stand by it with that open vest oh my
god well experts
experts say it is totally normal just
don't let it get out of hand i don't
they say it's normal to have a crush on
a cartoon
is this true have you guys ever had
crushes on fictional characters
well um hmm
i did on the incredibles that that lady
in the incredibles had a bit of a donkey
remember that yeah and like holly hunter
did her voice yeah
yeah
yeah listen here's i'm one of the
incredibles
she's
i never heard your alcoholic hunter oh
haven't you heard it she goes you have
no skills you have you know school
that's from broadcast news yeah i
actually asked this question once
of mike myers as well as garth i said to
wayne
did you ever find bugs bunny attractive
when he put on a dress and played a girl
bunny
so of course this is 30 years ago we
were talking about this kind of stuff
bugs bunny in a dress yeah and also
jessica rabbit even i was like okay girl
i got a yeah
way out of my league just the rabbit
mine is darth vader
what what
ever since i was a kid i really found
vader hot i think he's so sexy i know
it's like maybe there's dad issues there
i think i think there's there's
something there's a lot i also every
once in a while a mask can be hot you
don't know what's going on under there
it's a ton of mystery and you he just
will wrap you up in that cape and you
can do i had a dream where i used to
like press the buttons trying to escape
and then the cloak would come
closing in and i'd look up and the
camera would pan and there would be
darth and i felt something
you know
that is too funny
i like your answer better i did have
sort of i just had an admiration for
chewbacca
and um
[Music]
i called him up once and i said just
want to hang out as friends and always
all i heard on the phone was
well david spade and dana carvey oh all
your characters and you are just
everything and i love you guys so much
and check out their podcast fly on the
wall right now so you can find out fly
on the wall information from two
brilliant gentlemen um i'm actually on
the episode this wednesday thank you
again for having me to the party episode
wednesday thank you for tuning in
you guys are great
[Applause]
[Music]
you